yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressvpn comm slash yang
[Music]
when we were looking to give a million
bucks away to the folks in the Bronx
like I was like we have to make it so
every dime goes to a human like I do not
want to be like again not mad at
nonprofits like Run 1 but we gotta like
find a thousand people and give them a
thousand bucks and we did it I was very
proud of that we need more like that
where we just gotta get onto people's
hands and remember the Congress this is
the only silver lining can we're in a
deep dark hole it's a terrible
catastrophic time but there's a huge
appetite to do something differently
again 74% of Americans want cast relief
like we're gonna get President Biden and
then we're gonna need a new New Deal and
it's going to be hopefully a chance to
right some of the wrongs that have been
weighing our country down for
generations
[Music]
welcome back to Yankee this week I sit
down with Karen hunter whose radio show
I visited when I was running for
president really enjoyed this
conversation hope you do too we got
Andrew yang about to come in to talk
with us
maybe he'll be mayor of New York one day
I don't know but he's here today to talk
about basic income and a host of other
things that he's working on let me
welcome back to the show
our pal mr. Andrew yang gah hello Karen
thank you for having me it's great to be
here again I feel like I'm coming home
hey you know what that just gave me
chills and made me feel really good
inside thank you for that you are home
so you are I've had your mind you you've
been on my mind since well since the
last time you are but the the eleven
mayors throughout the country who signed
this letter about basic income and then
we're seeing another stimulus possibly
come down the pike and I was like if
they had just done the basic income
thing that Andrew yang was running on
maybe this wouldn't be such a horrific
time to be here in this country you're
100% right Karen where unfortunately now
we're in like this pandemic fueled
recession that could become a depression
and we need to get money into people's
hands so I've been doing my best to both
make that case to members of Congress
there's an emergency cash relief bill
that literally 74% of Americans support
just getting money into our hands what
can you think of something else 74% of
Americans support at this point what do
you have to do to try to get that higher
majority of Republicans and Democrats so
let's talk some sense into our
legislators and get economic relief into
our hands I wish it didn't have to be
like in this tragic and devastating a
time but it's overdue well Jack Dorsey
the CEO of Twitter just announced that
he's donating three million dollars to
those mayor's I think the the mayor
California Stockton
has been doing it successfully so he was
one of the the leading ones Chokwe
Lumumba Keisha Lance bottoms is a bunch
of mayors all over people I was on a
panel with mayor Tubbs of Stockton last
year and he said something to me I pipe
I'm not supposed to share a ball share
it because you know whatever we're here
but he said to me after the panel he
said like Andrew you can say [ __ ] I
could never get away with saying and and
what he meant by that was that like I
was just up there being like look we
have to value people intrinsically up
together give everyone a basic income
and the rest of it and last year he was
like if a young black mayor were to say
that like people would be like what the
heck are you talking about he's like but
now it's not just him it's Keisha Lance
bottoms
it's Ross Baraka and Newark it's mayors
around the country and they're gonna be
many more because if you're a mayor and
you see what's happening in your
community you're gonna say like wait a
minute like we need to do things
differently so tell me what the
disconnect is and I've watched it around
welfare I've watched it there's like
this notion in this country that if we
give somebody something that somehow it
takes something away from me and so it
is a weird thing but I literally watch
the government print money trillions of
dollars and give it to people and no one
had a problem with it and I'm like oh so
we could just print money and just give
it to people we could have been doing it
the whole time Karen I asked the brutal
truth and Martin Luther King saw this in
the 60s he was like we should have a
basic income today and he was killed
while he was making that case and
somehow we've been brainwashed into this
nonsense myth that like oh we don't have
enough to go around it's been nonsense
for a long time and this pandemic is
demonstrated to all of us when push came
to shove like you just said did we just
print four trillion dollars for Wall
Street when they needed a bailout yes
did we just print four trillion dollars
for big companies and to some extent
ourselves like during this pandemic yes
we can do it we just need enough members
of Congress to get on board with the
fact that they work for us they don't
work for Amazon they don't work for the
the giant Kampf
I've been laughing their way all the way
to the bank for the last number of years
and decades when you were talking about
universal basic income greedy election
cycle etcetera I was always wondering
like where there other places that
actually made it work and you're given a
couple of examples like even I saw
recently that you tweeted about South
Africa is on it's on its way to to
creating a floor for universal income
right talk about where the rest of the
world is on this because I think it's
such a foreign concept to so many so
many Americans that they think it's not
possible right but there are precedents
for this like literally in places
throughout the world
yeah South Africa just announced that
they're going to make it happen for
everyone India is actually implementing
a version of it
to tens hundreds of millions of people
Canada they did like a full-on ubi trial
in an entire town for years and in that
town
you saw better health mental health more
people starting businesses more people
going back to school it was beautiful
and when they found that data they were
like this is this is exactly what we
should have been doing this entire time
like the data is like Indiana Jones you
know like great as the Lost Ark we're
like that the data was like it's a
freaking file cabinet
where people were trying to keep it from
public eye but then when they found it
they were like oh my gosh like so
they're like you said there are examples
of this happening around the world and
the the most compelling example I think
tens of millions of Americans just
experienced is like everyone got 1,200
bucks and everyone liked it loved it
like it didn't make anyone all of a
sudden be like oh like work is for like
losers or something shut down because
you gave it citizens their money back
right like government didn't stop
because we gave citizen some of their
money back yes the opposite right yeah
and it helped the economy greatly it
like reduce the poverty rate but it also
went
right into local businesses to groceries
to fuel to rent and we are the citizens
and the stakeholders of the richest
society in the history of the world like
twenty two trillion dollars pre-crisis
we get a hundred percent afford this dr.
King knew it in the 60s he was like we
can afford this now he was right then
it's even more true today than it was
that it's just so baffling that there's
so much resistance and it's always
around this notion of laziness this myth
of laziness that will somehow you know
low people into not getting up and
pulling ourselves themselves up by their
bootstraps when you go online they're
watching who's they unfortunately a lot
of people and you know here on yang
speaks were big fans of our data being
ours and of data rights and of data
privacy we started the data dividend
project to fight for your data rights
but in the meantime what can you do so
that when you go online internet service
providers aren't keeping track of that
data and then selling it so what can you
do about it
incognito mode unfortunately doesn't
work quite as well as you hope it would
so what you can do is what a lot of
companies do for their employees you can
use a virtual private network now the
one that we recommend your yang speaks
is expressvpn it's an app that reroutes
your internet connection through their
secure servers so your isp can't see the
sites you visit it keeps all your
information secure by encrypting a
hundred percent of your data with the
most powerful encryption available you
click one button you forget about it you
don't even realize you have it on it's
like all of your devices are just
getting piped through this fancy fun new
network that you can call your own
protect your online activity today with
the VPN rated number one by C net and
wired visit my exclusive link expressvpn
comm slash yang and you can get an extra
three months free on a one-year package
that's expr ESS VPN dot-com slash yang
expressvpn com slash yang to learn more
keep your data safe and secure
[Music]
we're talking with two Andrews Andrew
McCaskill of course and Andrew yang you
also are out talking about police reform
and cash relief talk a little bit about
what what it is you're proposing
Andrew yang on the police reform side of
things I looked at the data because I'm
a data guy Karen and the data is
shocking where you're seeing cities
around the country pay out over a
billion dollars a year in civil suits
for police misconduct and brutality and
the legal standard to successfully sue a
police officer is very high so if you're
seeing successful suits that over a
billion dollars a year you know that the
magnitude of the problem is multiple
billions of dollars and this is
literally bankrupting some towns where
some cop does something reprehensible
and then the entire police department
gets now at this at this point you have
to look at it and say this is a rampant
problem and as like many of the problems
we're talking about has been in place
for years and when I talked to a black
lives matter activist about this he
actually hit the nail on the head he
said look local das cannot control cops
in their area because if you're the DA
in that area you literally rely upon law
enforcement every day just to do your
job and make cases and then for you to
turn around and being like hey bad cops
like we're gonna bust you all but like
the the local DA is like the Kamala
Harris case said the same thing she was
like you can't expect the locals to do
this so what I proposed was that you
need a federal Department of Justice
Commission that ideally be named after
George Floyd that all their mission was
was to investigate issues around police
misconduct and if you're a local DA you
would celebrate because finally it would
be something that's off your plate and
you know that their issues you know
there are bad cops in your area but you
can't do much about it and then you can
just say look like give it to the feds
and then the feds come in like it's the
only way that you would actually be able
to address this issue in my opinion
around the country in a real way that
would actually stand up over time
unfortunately the feds right now
is a trump administration fed and so
there's no appetite there to actually do
this with this current administration we
never had a department it's just this
disinterested injustice yeah they might
want to rename them themselves or the
could do what that actually gets after
the people's work there are a lot of
other things that we should do I mean a
lot of the things in the Democrats bill
were spot on around banning chokeholds
and getting data like one problem is
that if you have a bad cop that cop can
just go three counties over and all of a
sudden get hired again and you know you
it's a situation where you actually
aren't even sure the magnitude of the
problem it's one reason I went looking
for the data because police departments
don't actually report how many people
died in contact with police officers
every year even though they're legally
required to do so which you know it's a
terrible problem if like no one even
knows how bad the problem is like that's
a terrible terrible sign and just about
any any environment so there's also so
much work to do on this side Karen
certainly I think cash relief is part of
this too when I said that would George
Floyd have been there in that situation
if everyone was getting one or two
thousand dollars a month you know I
think that there was some issue around
like you know him needing to pay for
something and like people suspect to the
currency etc etc like let's just get
real money in everyone's hands and then
make it so that fewer people of color
are having run-ins with a police for for
like you know like everyday interactions
or issues as you sit home now and watch
as we trip into November you're no
longer running I you endorsed Joe Biden
but I don't think it's a cakewalk I
don't think it's gonna be a runaway I
think it's gonna be a very difficult
victory and I actually am nervous about
whether or not he could pull this out
have you been having conversations with
him about the person he selects his vice
president which i think is gonna be
probably the most important vice
presidential pick in our history what's
going to be your role in a Biden
administration cuz there should be one
and and give us something to hold on to
Andrew yang in terms of what you see
happening in November regarding this
election I talked to Joe last week
and I'm really very very positive on his
chances of becoming our next president
and again I'm the numbers guy where you
know the polls let us down in 2016
but the polls are pretty freakin uniform
this time around and they're even more
extreme than they were last time I think
Hillary had a point in like the at like
maybe a four point lead like Joe's lead
is something like twice that and the
lead holds up in places like Florida and
Michigan like a court in the polls Texas
is up for grabs you know you gotta look
up and say like if you're the average
American who voted for Donald Trump are
you eager to sign up for four more years
of this you know you like you're seeing
your economy shot to pieces you're
seeing people dying you're seeing him
just like inflamed racial problems
instead of trying to heal them like the
even the average Trump voter has to look
around and being like this is not good
like 72% of Americans said that this is
the worst time in American history that
they can ever ever remember
so that's 72% you know I mean I don't
know what the other 28% of people are
maybe they're really old and they
remember very very very awful but if 72%
of Americans think you're in the worst
time in American history in their
lifetimes that's not like let's reelect
like the current president like that's a
very very anti-incumbent type atmosphere
so I think Joe wins you know but then
after Joe wins the work begins we have
so much work to do we have to reinvent
this economy so that it works for
everyone listening to this for families
and towns that are being shattered right
now and I will be part of the
administration if Joe wants me to be one
of the things that they have floated by
me is to try and address our data rights
and Technology issues things that the
government frankly is way behind on and
Joe is expressed some openness and
enthusiasm for trying to build up some
kind of tech facing team and I may be
part of that team as it relates to that
when I think about how far advanced
other parts of the world are in terms of
protecting privacy individual the
privacy of individuals
as it relates to our privacy from our
tech providers goodies perspective what
we what we sort of are giving away
without any modicum of regulation here
or without legislators really understand
technology and we're giving away in
dollar terms hundreds of billions of
dollars a year like if you look at
Facebook and Google Facebook's revenue
is 70 billion a year Google is 160
billion a year that's almost a hundred
percent advertising and so they're
making all that money based on selling
and reselling our data to advertisers
and we all have had the experience where
you leave Facebook and the ads follow
you around you know you have some kind
of facebook conversation about a beach
vacation and all of a sudden like Aruba
ads are being shown to you like when
you're at a totally different site so
that's so that's eerie and spooky and
number one is like we're not seeing a
dime of that if our data is worth two
hundred billion a year plus like why are
we not seeing a red cent
so that's messed up the fact that our
preferences and opinions are subject to
so much of this interference some of it
which may be corrupt or even foreign or
ideologically extreme like that's a mess
the fact that our mental health is
actually diminishing particularly for
young people particularly for young
girls in part because of the way that
social media incentives are set up where
and I use social media a lot you know
yang Yang and all of that but the fact
is that if you're the social media
company you get paid based upon trying
to advertise to us and so everything you
do is going to be designed to try and
maximize engagement and snap streaks and
the rest of it and so if you're a
fourteen-year-old girl and you know
you're you're getting cyber bullied or
whatnot or being subject to various
negative influences like there's no
counterweight within that tech company
to try and look out for our kids it's
all about who what the advertisers want
like how they can make the most money so
it's bad for our sense of self our
humanity our pocketbooks and wallets our
democracy
our mental health what's going on right
now with our data and I would love to
turn that around I'm working on things
right now to try and turn that around
but I think the Abidin administration is
going to move light-years faster what do
you do a third of your life ideally
sleep what are you doing on a mattress
what do you need a mattress that you can
sleep on and happily keep blake's sleep
offers just that it is a high-end
mattress and they send to you in a box
you just bust it out and then snuggle up
on a pillow I think they throw a free
pillow into this action and they've won
awards they were like the overall
mattress pick of 2019 and 2020 by GQ and
Wired magazine so you know there was
some Wired editor the sleeping on these
mattresses being like this is the one
what a giddy
they chose helix leave and we to our
fans just going to helix sleep dot-com /
yeah take your two minutes sleep quiz we
just fun because you get to answer
questions about how you sleep and
they'll match you with a customized
mattress that gives you the best sleep
of your life what is the best sleep of
your life feel like I don't know but you
can find out and they'll give you a 10
year warranty you can try it out for a
hundred nights you can sleep on that
mattress for three months risk-free and
I'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will that's a lot
of confidence in this mattress so good
you like sleep calm and they're offering
$200 off all mattress orders to three
pillars for our listeners at helix sleep
comm / yeah that's helix ato IX sleep
common / yeah - good dogs off I just did
this I took the quiz you put in your
name you can put in your partner's name
you can choose a side that you want
that's firm or soft if you sleep on your
back you sleep on your side you have
back pain in the morning do you not then
they this magical wheel spins and then
it tells you mattress to order and then
they ship at you in a box and a bed
frame
and if you use our code you get two free
pillows and $200 off so it is as easy as
advertised it's beautiful it's
comfortable it's simple helix leap comm
slashing 200 ollars off as I'm listening
to you again I'm lamenting man you know
it would be nice and if you live in New
York as we you know Drew does from time
to time I'm wondering if you are going
to throw your head are you gonna
announce on this show today that you're
gonna be running for mayor of New York
I'm just curious
I love the question just just in that
like it's it's incredibly invigorating
to be considered for it right now
focused on helping Joe win get Trump out
like yet get a new team in DC and then
we'll look at the opportunities for air
for you know for me in terms of how to
have a positive impact but I Love New
York I certainly want to see New York
back on its feet as soon as possible and
and on that your father you you're
raising kids in New York there's this
drumbeat from the president to send kids
back into the classroom or else or else
funding will be withheld what are your
thoughts on that as somebody that also
has children in the New York City school
system yeah I have a car I've
conversation with my wife about this on
the regular as you know we are all
having within our households and there
is real truth to the fact that like that
there are you know a million different
situations are around the country and
there are real harms to not having your
kids in school like you know like we all
saw the beginnings of it with our kids
being out in the spraying and if you
have that at home time compound in the
fall like some of these kids will be
significantly behind and their
development will it will be you know
less than what you want it to be now
that's one side of the equation what is
the other side like how safe to people
feel like if you send your kids into
school like are you confident really
that you know in my case like seven year
olds are going to social dissin
from each other of course not their kids
like you know like yeah the odds of them
all like wearing masks and staying like
6 feet away from each other are
approximately zero so you have to to
look at that at the other side and say
okay like you know what are the health
concerns where the teachers on this and
I you know you you know teachers are
going to be obviously mixing with these
kids on the like on the regular and so
that there are real massive issues to
balance it's not like a black or white
or like you know right or wrong thing in
my mind because there are so many
different situations for different kids
different families different communities
if you're in a part of the country where
frankly kovat is not rampant and like
you know your kids need school then like
ideally your school does reopen and your
kids back in that school if you're in a
community where Co vid is spreading like
wildfire and hospitals don't have
capacity then it's a very very different
picture I'm happy to say it seems like
New York now is edging towards like
being one of the the clearer
environments because we've taken it
seriously because we had to pay such a
tragic devastating price early on yeah
but it also there's no cure yet and so
you can be clear today and not tomorrow
14 days later there could be another
wave so I just an on that you know this
president took took the opportunity to
constantly refer to this virus as the
China virus or the Wu Han flu and things
like that and as a man from the with an
Asian background what were your thoughts
and what was he trying to do and what
was the impact that a fallout from that
no I was talking to a family member
about this like trumps like a basketball
player who I was like one move and then
like you take the move away he doesn't
know what else to do he just keeps going
to it so in his case it's like my move
is racially inflammatory and divisive
rhetoric and if I'm getting called the
task for the fact that I've let this
pandemic run rampant and wreck the
economy and kill tens of thousands of
Americans maybe if I call it the China
virus or come flu or like Wuhan flu or
whatever like I can like change the
conversation and just like make it so
that people are
greet each other or distracted so from
my perspective was like look let's just
like focus on the real issues that we
all care about which is our health our
family's health whether our kids are
gonna go back to school
and like keep the focus on the fact that
this administration has failed us in
historic mammoth fashion so clearly as
an Asian American obviously I think that
that kind of stuff is nonsense and
hateful and divisive but I just don't
want it to work like you know just like
keep the focus on the president's
performance and then we get him out of
there and then we can start to heal the
country and do the hard work of digging
ourselves out it would be nice ignored
but there were people that were actually
you know abused attack oh yeah as a
result of this so you know I'm strange
too I mean like the hatred and fear and
hostility towards Asian Americans has
surged to a level that you know friends
and family have never seen before like
you know kids being stabbed and like
people being beaten like in acid being
thrown in someone's face randomly like
you know this real real venom and hatred
that has no place in America yeah it
it's heartbreaking you know and like the
different but the thing I try and put
back in perspective it's like well I
mean you also have African Americans
dying of kovat at like three four or
five times the rate of other Americans I
mean like we're all suffering in
different ways and you know like tent to
me like the goal has to be trying to do
as much good as possible and yet a sound
and not let certainly President Trump
distract us from what's most important
[Applause]
it's the age-old question how do you
find the people you're looking for when
you're looking to hire business and on
the flip side how do you find someone
who's looking for someone just like you
indeed is a great way for both employers
and folks who are looking to take the
next step in terms of finding a job it's
gonna pay the bills keep everyone's head
above the water so when Andrew and I
were running a campaign we ended up
having to hire hundreds of people in the
matter of two to three weeks
it was the most insane time the campaign
I'd I can't tell you how stressed the
staff was and tech platforms like indeed
where our saving grace where you're able
to just find quick talent understand
where they're coming from where they are
their experience their specific
expertise are identified their
professional focuses and filter them
they quickly interview hire as fast as
possible so we are big fans of indeed
and without platforms like this I can't
tell you how we were already we were
already breaking things and moving as
fast as we could I can't say how much
Messier would have been on the campaign
so if you're a small business or
medium-sized business looking to hire
and hire fast indeed is the place to go
for sure your first job coats to give it
a try and get in front of quality
candidates go to indeed.com slash yang
that's indeed.com slash yang juice
September thirtieth seventy five bucks
off your first job help us to see
whether it works for you and your
business
[Music]
[Applause]
so now what
you know I wait until November I just
feel on some level not helpless because
you know as long as we have breath in
our body we can make a difference
whether we talk about our community in
our in our own backyard but it does feel
like we're it's a waiting game to
November to see what happens because as
long as that man is in office partnering
so guilty abusing the power that that he
has been imbued with and it's disgusting
you know as a student of history to
watch this man abuse that office in this
manner you know I just feel like we're
we're in a holding pattern until
November okay there's so much for us to
do between now and then certainly number
one is some of these local races like I
was excited for Jamal Bowman I'm excited
for some of the folks that my
organization's endorsing right now we
got a primary tomorrow on Tuesday in
Austin Texas this great candidate Donna
imum is running that I endorse so like
literally like every week there's like
another race that I'm like trying to
pump energy and resources and votes
towards yeah like there's another
candidate who just came out as a mayor
for universal basic income Alex Morse in
Massachusetts who's great freaking
brilliant guys for basic income so if we
can get some folks into DC one of the
things so we started this conversation
on emergency cash relief which I'm
clearly a hundred percent behind and to
me how can you be a member of Congress
who's a Democrat and not be for cash
relief you know like like you're you
need to go and we need to get someone in
there who will actually say like look
during a pandemic giving money to people
as obvious
so right now 41 representatives and like
a smaller number of members of Congress
including Kamala Harris and Bernie and
Ed Markey support the cash relief bill
and one of the ways we can get cash
relief passed is by having members of
Congress who are not for casually
have challengers come up say I'm for
cash relief why the heck are you not for
cash relief and then you either get the
current member out and a new person in
who's for cash relief or you put
pressure on the current person to switch
and so that to me is like job one right
now is we gotta call our members of
Congress and say look you're gonna pass
another stimulus bill which they will I
guarantee you neither sentiments oppose
coming you got to get more bit for the
people for us for the humans we do not
care about the mega corpse they can go
in a bankruptcy for all we care like I
care about myself my aunt my friends my
neighbors get us the money and so we
need to make that case and one great way
to make that case is by like supporting
people who are for it and if you're not
for it you need to go so so that's
immediate another thing that we can do
is is just lend a hand like thanks to
some people like Jack Dorsey like my
organization's given almost 7 million
dollars in direct economic relief
including a million dollars straight to
a thousand families in the Bronx earlier
in the spring I can't believe it's
summer now that's crazy so so so we need
to just lend a hand because there's so
much suffering so many people and we
can't wait until DC gets its act
together like we just got to do
everything we can to put people on a
better path when we've been giving this
$250 or 500 or a thousand dollars to
people Karen tears of joy you know it's
like it's incredibly invigorating and
saddening at the same time that there's
so many Americans that if you gave them
five hundred bucks it would be like the
difference between eating and not eating
or being able to feed their kids and not
feed their kids so anything we can do to
help on that side we should do and for
what it's worth Andrew Young is very
positive people how to participate in
that oh I would love that
so our organizations website is move
humanity forward calm we've given 7
million in direct economic relief any
money you give to us we're going to turn
around and give to someone in need and
yeah hopefully we can get up to that ten
million dollar level pretty quick but
the need is so vast you can also request
help at that website
so everyone you're listening to this and
you need a hand you can put your name
down it's pretty quick we do have a
massive waiting list now so no promises
but if you need help please do just put
your name down and if you can provide
help give what you can and we'll turn it
around and give it to someone else
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the age-old question how do you
find the people you're looking for when
you're looking a higher business and on
the flip side how do you find someone
who's looking for someone just like you
indeed is a great way for both employers
and folks who are looking to take the
next step in terms of finding a job it's
gonna pay the bills keep everyone's head
above the water
so when Andrew and I were running a
campaign we ended up having to hire
hundreds of people in the matter of two
to three weeks
it was the most insane time the campaign
I'd I can't tell you how stressed the
staff was and tech platforms like indeed
where our saving grace where you're able
to just find quick talent understand
where they're coming from where they are
their experience their specific
expertise are identified their
professional focuses and filter them
they quickly interview hire as fast as
possible so we are big fans of indeed
and without platforms like this I can't
tell you how we were already we were
already breaking things and moving as
fast as we could I can't say how much
Messier would have been on the campaign
so if you're a small business or
medium-sized business looking to hire
and hire fast indeed is the place to go
for sure your first job coats to give it
a try and get in front of quality
candidates go to indeed.com slash yang
that's indeed.com slash yang juice
September thirtieth
seventy five bucks off your first job
focus to see whether it works for you
and your business
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm choose what you think about some of
the large corporations that are now
starting to to pledge dollars to
communities particularly I'm thinking
about the dollars place to the
african-american community or racial or
social justice or even some of the
organization some of the corporations
they're pledging dollars toward COBIT
they're coded response what what would
you advise those organizational
companies where to spend that money how
to actually make that money or what
should we be you should be looking for
asking for from those organizations as
they're saying we're going to give these
dollars we're going to make these these
donations in these check what should we
be looking for or asking them to do it
that way I'm a huge fan of Direct Relief
you know like if the money was going
straight into people's wallets and
pocketbooks that would be ideal I like
it when firms stand up and try and do
the right thing they say like hey look
I'm gonna give five million dollars to
communities of color I've been in those
offices and you know what they do when
they're in this situation they look
around and say okay who can we give the
money to that will stand up to like a
very very high degree of corporate
scrutiny or press scrutiny and then
they'll try and identify various
nonprofits that are reputable and can be
trusted and then maybe if you have five
million to give to communities of color
you say look find me the five top
nonprofits that are working on various
issues then you give them each a million
each
you have press releases those leaders
are happy great love it how much of that
money ends up reaching folks who are
desperate right now for groceries in the
rest of it probably not quite as much as
you'd hope you know and and and not to
be mad at anything that's going on like
I've run a nonprofit that I started you
know if you gave us a million bucks like
we'd be incredibly grateful we do great
stuff with it
we'd pay our people first obviously
because you know like it's not like
these nonprofits are swimming and
resources necessarily all the time
so like some good work could be done but
there would be a lot of people that
would never see a dime of that and so
it's a different type of challenge but
if you're a company you feel like you
got to go to a name-brand partner yeah
Jordan I've been having this
conversation just about every week
because we know what you just said it's
true and we need to do more of what
you're actually doing
move move humanity forward move humanity
forward dot-com so Andrew first of all
thank you for being here today we
appreciate you we appreciate the
partnership you're a guy that really
does care about people and that's
important to us here just in general
because everyone is so political
everything's so political everything's
about you know putting on the right face
and head and saying the right things and
having the right sound bites you
actually do care you that that was what
you ran for president on and you're
still doing it so uh I'm I'm really
grateful that you're part of this family
here I like you care and I'm grateful to
you for having me on back when I was
running now I'll come back any time and
we just have to do what's right for us
and our people we know like if you talk
to the average person like you know they
know how to solve their own problems
best we just got to get money into your
hands so you can actually solve your own
problems when we were looking to give a
million bucks away to the folks in the
Bronx like I was like we have to make it
so every dime goes to a human like I do
not want to be like again not mad at
nonprofits like run one but we gotta
like find a thousand people and give
them a thousand bucks and we did it I
was very proud of that we need more like
that where we just gotta get people's
hands and remember the Congress this is
the only silver lining can we're in a
deep dark hole it's a terrible
catastrophic time but there's a huge
appetite to do something differently
again seventy four percent of Americans
want cash relief like we're gonna get
President Biden and then we're gonna
need a new New Deal and it's gonna be
hopefully a chance to right some of the
wrongs that have been weighing our
country down for generations elections
have consequences people you got to vote
you gotta take care of business and
every gang you come back anytime sir
appreciate you follow a game thank you
for listening in I hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notification so we can let you
know every time we have a new episode